the evacuation efforts continue here
bringing in some of the elderly and the
firm
we're not sure exactly where this
elderly woman has been taken from but
she's obviously very weak indeed we're
told that there's still around a
thousand people either trapped or
refusing to be evacuated in this area
and meanwhile there's a seemingly
increasing threat of shelling we've
heard a lot of outgoing today the
military are warning us that there
wouldn't be at all surprise if there was
a response and shelling from the Russian
occupied side of the river also but as I
say some very harrowing scenes here
as these the elderly the sick and the
infirm
pulled out of their buildings many of
which are still under meters